handset oh my god I got absolutely mad
wife's everyone welcome to the couch you
can't see us but I am joined by Lucy and
two more play in the four honor closed
betta betta because we are English
because we English I am the Orochi Tammy
planners what do I can see this so the
other samurai man Lucy you are I think
I'm some kind of berserker it's a Viking
lady right I'm a Viking to axed lady
sick I'm gonna ax you a question you
guys are being ganged up on help me so
Tam and I gamescom last year played this
for like four hours and it was a truly
devastating story because we captured
all the footage and then it didn't work
never say sorry oh so straight up I'm
just gonna kill this fool I'm going like
all the way mobbed already some of them
too I'm just my kite is quite squishy
but they do a lot of damage so I'm
trying to be a bit clever and not run at
the Raider with a giant axe this is a
game in which you like it's gotta focus
on a 1v1 battles but often you can find
yourself outnumbered and in that
scenario it's very difficult to do
anything get oh wow that frame rates
these are the beta they've got time
slammed against the ground of here there
we go all right get out of my way oh my
days they're nuts so I'm just killing
creeps right now hi cool Oh get house be
point at least try to get beat you find
that guy on a time oh my god that's two
of them Oh to hold up i'm running back
to you oh I'm gonna die rolle nice it
captured well played good team up throws
me glad you to the point that was one of
our teammates that Lucy tell you Lucy
what what did i do you just leave and go
down to go down uh don't know we're
gonna fight away sure why not let's to
that guys like me on this horn camping
how dare you are died
you'll be avenged yeah well go oh yeah
mate okay in the gear up guy just and be
honest oh yeah um we play this like four
hours behind few months ago and I
remember really enjoying it at the time
we did some of the one one-on-ones rules
man if you manage to run into someone
and like run them off a cliff OS take
him into a brazier or something and it
is so satisfying why is that going
collecting it I'm Oh revenge revenge
punch oh god oh brother I'm just gonna
run away oh I am at their spawn get away
I'm gonna die you scum oh I got poked in
the ribs poke to the ribs until I was
dead is this you do not yeah over five
mean I know you're good Oh how'd it get
on a self bike retreat some people have
a passive yeah yeah I think I do I have
a if I if I kill some when i get my
health back shame i gotta run Dre into a
bomb yeah I got that all four of them
it's gonna be a fall before it's good
before before hey all right you guys
yeah being chosen loose you've been
chosen yeah i know i'm gonna point it
i'm gonna ignore me happy about stands
i'm at stands I'm get hurt like creep
your point see this is not a time for
the framerate to die on me yeah you
better run
oh this is a glowstone my girl buried i
buy a minion oh I'll come and revive you
can't believe I'm do say no carnal baby
and being attacked oh I'm gonna shine
what no holding them their own points
but I'm going murked my characters meant
to be like an assassin see and it's a
pic dudes off yeah Oh is not good mark
to be on tracing this Ned I am very glad
they're having this open Bo way ahead of
time because damn if there's some
networking issue who's yeah okay I need
help on see uh come oh no I was on beat
come in does any of this stuff um carry
on her dearly no oh oh Dave like
probably a hundred percent won't I'm
dead although i dead okay well I've come
someone's really low though so you can
ya know pick someone off help me oh god
I don't want it to anh tuan to think
times coming is punished well I mean
that's me well is Ariane what I'm just
running I'm straight running away fall
back I will cover your escape oh I'm
behind them brothers what major don't
know they still chasing me know guys we
talked about this we didn't talk about
it at all but right it's John to now
I've taken one Apple I'm fighting them
but I've got like big goons on me as
well friendly fires all in it like
friend if I doesn't do quite as much
damage as little fire but it like
staggers you what's second Viking a
picture where you out guys Oh dead on
the ground need someone's dollars yes
please yeah um how many time me and you
break
I you thought if I can you take the
sometimes there's no quite a few of the
place in the Viking where you boys that
would buy this form ok it's comp is it
oh god I gotta step away ghost em away
it's gone bananas smoke bomb I am out oh
no I'm gonna die I'm so dying oh god you
led me into it is he helped uh well turn
around I feel like we're getting man
really muscled yes yes by these know no
Kerry go to mr. momentum Lucy distracted
that character that and I'm able to turn
it I'm come to help Luke alright cool
i'll get this son samurais flanking
around us yeah right you and me on this
dude Oh is so much are you able T to
three on save on UFC hey baby maybe one
of the house get on my way come to me
listen to me Oh what oh you know how I
said I cool it was come on you I love
them oh my god of I was running on
someone else off I love the rocket new
guest um picture quick chat wow good
like I'm fine in the middle of like 30
enemies oh I'm gonna go a loose took it
okay guys topic a lot of I kill that guy
I need didn't die what of course see
this is gonna be a battle
all right I'm gonna try and going oh
nice just like c-usa yes you just got
destroyed friend get out of my house my
be my zone 8 is secure how we've got to
see as wanna say for the only one sobeys
being a sleaze by who 02 it's one up
this one cup of the ladder I think race
that way wait hang on no imma be no I'm
my being sick right we need backup a
it's like come in all of us hey all
right we got beat r you gonna be it's my
bad it's not a break-in I'm here Oh help
okay they're all up yeah I know I'm with
you I'm with you when you stay mobile
scatter oh god I'm a fire yeah I didn't
think I'm just gonna quietly go back
here I'm very low health and I'm on fire
all right they should only host team by
my single rose it's too violent oh yeah
I got bloody shot with an arrow all
right i had a damn i retreated other
side don't respond you i'm coming to
revive you and say oh god I got
absolutely merked I'm with you Sam you
mean all right you me it's good eh
there's only three of them left if I con
lam regain the momentum
right where is that recaps right okay
you're a all right yes Sam I was running
I don't think I've killed a single
person it's honorable I'm innocent
focusing on capturing oh god I they're
just respawned all right I'm with you
well behind behind others Oh barbarian
be there mobs gain momentum oh my god
okay yeah that's 200 don't don't one
this right sick one damn those barbarian
her he means nothing to me all right
he's got a nexus one man i distract him
I'm get my bow oh god damn i don't know
i buy a pot say that we're done there's
one unbeaten lon help her so good is
that you dead over there Lucy almost
certainly oh man getting worked by all
these these are AI enemies just go down
really quickly what they em yeah boom
yeah get sniped son they're dangerous in
large groups but they go down frequently
yeah we're gonna see that we roughly how
are they recovering points have one guys
just by himself go for my wife is going
to be down he's right at you try to
raise his mates all right I'm gonna gain
happen to me ain't happening ain't
happening oh we got see look my stamina
slower might need help with his
barbarian marine by their respawn point
thank you
boom nailed him victory oh this is a bit
we just kill and everyone is all the way
dead well if you guys want to see some
for on a gameplay that isn't just three
idiots running around the battlefield
pretending they know what they're doing
then you can click on the top right the
video and you'll see some gameplay over
on gamespot's YouTube until next time
thank you so much for watching remember
to hit that like button subscribe for
more def videos like this one and we'll
see you next time
you